we as an investor
we are generally sort of sector
generalist investors so we don't focus
on any specific industries and we're in
a way we're on the receiving end so
there are like you know this universe of
founders who are producing something
every year and we are there receiving
the you know the fruits of their
production so to say of their
imagination and creativity
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel and in media
partnership with c-tec
welcome to 20-minute leaders today i am
being joined by alexander klonopliasti
general partner and co-founder of
flashpoint
alex and his business partner michael
set up the investment from in 2012
having met during their time at moscow
state institute of international
relations alex holds a degree in
international economic relations and has
previously worked for price waterhouse
coopers morgan stanley and ubs he serves
as a board member of several companies
including ivi a russian streaming
service and guestie property management
software alex conoclasti welcome to 20
minute leaders from flashpoint venture
capital how are you
i'm all good michael thanks for having
me today it's a pleasure to uh walk uh
talk with you about uh us and also share
some insights that might be curious for
your listeners
i'm very very excited for all of that
i'm excited to hear about your own
journey into flashpoint venture capital
i'm especially excited to hear your
insights into the proptech and
construction tech space what is
happening around the world where the
innovation is taking place what have you
learned from the investments that you've
done you've been very active in the
israeli ecosystem talking about some you
know expanding your investments here and
i'm excited to to pick your brain in
these next 20 minutes or so both on your
own journey but also on the vc side so
alex perhaps give me a little bit of an
overview of what flashpoint is and then
your decision working with israel and
then we'll dive into prop tech and
construction tech
absolutely absolutely michael be my
pleasure uh and feel free to you know
interrupt me at any point in time if you
have any clarifying questions uh i will
thank you
my wife thinks i'm a talkative person so
i can
wonderful yeah i mean uh usually about
myself so i was born in kiev uh
40 years ago uh and
my life since then was quite
international so we
together with my parents i lived in
azerbaijan in germany
in russia
in ukraine and then i was lucky to be a
scholar of one of the us programs so i
was an exchange student in high school
in the states that's how i learned my
english and that's got that's what got
me into one of the
um top universities uh in europe and um
basically after that i got a job with
morgan stanley in london
and i've been always doing telecom media
and technology
firstly as a banker and now now as an
investor
flashpoint was founded in 2012
uh we launched it together with my
friend michael uh who was my uh roommate
in the dormitory uh so michael is
hungarian so with michael we go back and
already like 20 23 years
uh so it's more of a
relationship than the friendship um and
you know we started flashpoint with our
own money so we pledged about five
million dollars of our own money that we
made through our professional careers we
decided not to buy you know any ferraris
or expensive real estate we decided that
you know everything needs to be invested
in the business our wives were not as
excited about that part um but um
hopefully it's gonna uh prove proof uh
prove different we have started
investing our own money um and uh
basically today we are about 400 million
assets under management
uh we are
a team of about
uh of about uh 30 people um and our our
vision for flashpoint is that we would
like to build a company actually that
does asset management uh
uh across uh in technology space and uh
what we mean by that is that we would
like to provide various types of capital
to founders across their journey as they
build large public companies so as they
exit
so we not only would like to focus on
see the series a we would also like to
support these founders along along their
way
and also you know our dream always was
to build something international because
we all worked in the international
organization so focusing on one
geography or being very local is not is
not as exciting
and it's not only supporting founders
out of a specific country let's say from
israel doing something in the us
um because then you're still like more
israeli focused but you know
supporting more international more
international businesses so that's why
we decided to focus on eastern european
founders including israel is it like a
broader
european uh uh
part of europe um and the founders who
are building international companies so
they are mostly focused on the u.s
western europe or in you know other
international geographies so that's the
that's the focus of our business um and
uh we do mostly software uh we do mostly
software uh that's our main sort of uh
theme um
and uh
um originally we started from venture
capital uh so that was our first product
and in venture capital we get involved
um
basically at the stage where uh you you
have uh you have already tested your
product market fit and you understand
that this is the product that fits
certain customer use cases and then you
start to basically scale that so you
need to hire more sales marketing r d
and that's where i think
we as an investor we found you know
ourselves to be valuable and helpful to
the founders because we're not as much
product people
to be involved at an earlier stage where
you're still you know iterating the
product thinking you know which way
direction to go thinking about your your
fit but we are more about scaling and
scaling requires hiring people that's
the most important thing i think
especially in some of the geographies in
israel in particular i think right now
it's a very challenging environment to
be hiring top talent uh because you know
everyone hiring a lot of companies are
booming so it's very hard to find people
who are
fixing you and then you know retaining
those people
and secondly i think it's about
fundraising uh so if you're growing very
fast you need to be able to raise
capital uh pretty much constantly and
thirdly i think what is important and
where we are focusing is building the
company itself right so processes a lot
of the companies get involved with they
have 10 to 20 30 maybe employees maximum
and then in the years to come several
years to come they grow from 30 to 300.
and we have a case like that let's say
just in israel one of the first
companies we supported in israel uh we
have led their series a already like
four or five years ago uh so they were i
think
15 17 people they were probably like you
know 50 70k mrr
relatively still small company but um
that has grown tremendously now they
have you know several hundred people
working in the company
um so basically you know you need to
build this company together right you
need to think about you know efficiency
what works what doesn't work you know
how to how to build the organization
um right that's what we're focused on
and that's why and that's where i think
we as flashpoint that's how we see all
of this geography sort of united
together in a way uh because the
problems that you need to solve being a
polish founder or finnish founder a
check founder israeli founder is the
same and it's very different from let's
say germany france uk is in us where the
markets are big and you don't need to go
outside your home geography
and solving the same problems for you as
an investor that's something that is you
know scale in a scalable manner so you
don't need to reinvent the wheel every
time i think it's quite important that's
why we like this geography we'll focus
on that um
now besides the geography
and besides geography and the
internationalization of what you're
talking about here specifically you've
come to think quite
quite a lot about the prop tech and
construction tech space
through your investments as well i don't
believe that the thesis of flashpoint is
specifically in those spaces and looking
at the other investments as well but but
this is something that you've gotten to
understand quite well
tell me a little bit about this because
this is not a space that the average
entrepreneur immediately is drawn to
absolutely
michael thank you for the question i
think uh maybe uh just uh you know to
also mention that you know we as an
investor uh we are generally sort of
sector generalist investors so we don't
focus on any specific industries and
we're in a way we're on the receiving
end so there are like you know this
universe of founders who are producing
something every year and we are there
receiving the you know the fruits of
their production so to say of their
imagination and creativity uh on one
hand on the other hand there are certain
industries that we like
and
you know their construction and prop
tech is one of them there are some
others that we like as well including
education health tech we've done a
number of deals on those industries as
well and we go and proactively search
and research this industry so in
proptech
we have done already you know like a
handful of investments in israel we have
done in total eight deals we haven't
invested about 30 million
i think in israel in the last let's say
four
four years and out of these eight
companies um basically three are in
proptech and uh we just announced this
morning uh in a a an investment in the
company called trustor they raised four
and a half million dollars where we
collect the the transaction together
with one of the local israeli funds
uh so for us it's it's an interesting
and important sector the reason why
we're focusing on on and started
focusing on that space is that i think
uh
for several reasons one of them is that
uh in general property construction has
been like a very boring and traditional
market uh where you have a large
physical assets
and
very large operators globally you know
beat hotels construction companies um
you know business center managers uh who
are have been basically managing these
physical assets and i think uh we work
in the way it was one of the like um
pioneers uh venturing into the space in
a big way because they said okay you
know let's uh let's reinvent the whole
you know office management and i think
so i think
there were a couple of people like that
including airbnb for example as well so
there were like a lot several pioneers
in the space in general who pushed
automation into the niche
and i think today uh i would
maybe mention a couple of other drivers
one of them is
general proliferation of technology
devices and combination of that so
tablets you know mobile smartphone
devices because i think people uh same
people like you and me were you know
already like
i don't know me they were still young
but we've grown up and in our regular
lives we have all of these devices but
then you go on your construction site
and and you're opening up you know paper
maps and and there is like a
basically a like a big contrast with
your normal life and i think people
like as the generations have started to
change people realize that you know you
can utilize a lot more technology in
construction in the same way as you do
in some other some of the spaces and and
lastly i think corvette in general i
we're seeing that covet has given a
significant push um with all the social
distancing you know uh contact tracing
and other things um it has given a
definitely a push to how people are
thinking about accessing construction
sites you know
and working around that um
and
on one hand on the other hand
i think uh
um it has become also a very diversified
industry so if you think about the
verticals only in israel there are
probably about like several hundred
startups in the construction and pro
space in the last couple of that have
been booming and that includes you know
uh various property management software
like guestie who has you know race
series uh you know bc and recently they
announced a round led by apox raising a
50 million dollar round which we are
super excited um
and uh uh and uh happy to be you know uh
partners of such such great uh investors
uh but there are there are
there they're very you know various
verticals that have appeared around like
project management around planning
around you know financing insurance uh
taking payments so a lot of verticals
and i think this proliferation of
various verticals gives birth to further
you know uh capabilities so for example
trustor what they're doing is they are
enabling essentially
data collection at the construction site
uh to ensure safety and productivity so
they actually have you know certain
hardware that they install uh on the on
the on the side uh to track the device's
people and also see you know how the
construction place is managed and you
know they come on top of some other
technology which they have not developed
necessarily themselves but because of
like this whole technologies text that
appears i think a lot more solutions are
prone to appear and that's what gets us
very excited because you know this whole
construction space is a you know a
huge market and i think
uh we we expect uh expect to see more
coming out of that
okay and that makes a lot of sense now
as you're approaching and seeing a lot
of
a lot of you know
companies in the seed stage in the
series a stage you know what what have
you been starting to to get either
intuitively or or you know really by the
book that you know some red flags that
you're that you're observing
so some things that are popping out you
that perhaps you know somebody with less
experience wouldn't necessarily think
that it's such a big deal but you're
observing you're saying okay there's
something here that is that is touching
a sensitive subject
yeah i think for us as an investor i
think uh
you know there's obviously no perfect uh
perfect like uh hit uh sometimes you're
seeing
but things which which are catching the
eye for example especially at the early
stages is
how
good is the management team and how
efficiently they've been building the
company so the ideal you know hit for an
investor is that you know there is a
company that is founded by you know
relatively energetic uh people with a
lot of charisma
which which comprises you know both uh
product people r d people and sales
people so that's like the ideal mix if
if you can get all of that in one
founding team that's remarkable and
we're mostly talking about b2b products
and then i think usually these people
start they take some of their own money
some of the friends and family money and
then the ideal kit is that you take this
little amount of capital and you get a
certain result so you manage to build
some product which attracts and start
generating revenue so that's the ideal
scenarios most of the times of course
people take their own money they spend
it you know it's not as successful so
they have to go back and take more money
and maybe even more money and that's
when this you know one of the first red
flags starts to appear if people spend
too much money you know let's say they
spent i don't know 10 million dollars
and they have revenue
only of later on 20 000 per month right
and we see situations like that and
we're saying it quite often today yeah
sometimes it can be it is sometimes you
know i i we actually have been proven
wrong a couple of times where people
have actually spent a lot uh but then uh
and raised the you know several rounds
uh and we passed on that situation
because we were not as convinced and the
product was still like you know but then
they ended up actually becoming
successful so but um and i think the
team the team composition i think is
also quite important because i think
it's very important to have the right
product guy uh who most of the time is
the ceo uh and then he himself is also
the salesperson so this like combination
of product and sales and then there is a
strong uh you know technical co-founder
uh sometimes teams are missing that and
i think that's um
and and lastly i think uh i i think uh
you know one for us one of the red flags
is also you know how
how people have raised money like before
us because sometimes they do like
deals so the founders like the initial
investor manages to get to like a very
sweet deal for himself
and then he tries to reprice us
reprice this deal substantially thus
hurting the founders because the
founders would get diluted you know
quite significantly between the initial
round where they have to give away let's
say 30 of the company
and then they need to get diluted
another 20 right so that three and and
you're still at like post-seat stage
you're not serious a yet right and you
already have given away 20 you know half
of your company it's not more uh
so this is like having enough motivation
for the management team by the time the
company starts having let's say 100 000
of revenue per month it's it's um it's
important that the team is motivated
enough to keep on going because that's
only the start of the journey it might
have taken them already like three four
five years to get even here but they
don't realize it's another 10 years from
here at least right and and that's i
think is super important to make sure
people are modulated so we are looking
and then of course there are some other
like metrics around financials operating
kpis and how people think about
economics of their business because
sometimes you see businesses that are
scaling they're starting to scale before
they reach the point where they
understand it's efficient where you know
lifetime value over customer acquisition
cost is actually a meaningful number and
they produce you know value added
uh to the whole environment and planet
earth by having their own product
because a lot of times it's like
negative or very small and then the
question is
guys you should just you know change
something you should like turn over the
page and move on maybe um
wow and so
you know as you're looking today
at your journey and you're looking at
the you know the work and you're having
more 400 million dollars under
management what really inspires you in
your day-to-day right now
yeah i think uh so you know
this is the number i mean we don't think
a lot about like uh the overall number
and that we got like somewhere i think
for us uh it's about uh daily challenges
i think we
we we are a team and together with
michael initially you know we believe
that we ourselves will like solving
problems right so we're problem solvers
and we like being challenged and every
business every company building be
successful or not it's solving problems
on a daily basis uh and we're not afraid
of these problems so we take them as a
new you know adventure as step by step
and we go on and and and try to deal
with them
um i think the second thing uh besides
that is the i think technology attracts
in general very talented and uh
interesting people i think that's
probably one of the most exciting uh
for us
because uh we work with very interesting
investors or investors people who have
seen a lot and can share their
experience we work with a lot of
founders and it's a fast fast fast-paced
environment right so unlike some other
professions which are less fast paced
this one is definitely fast paced in
terms of things happening the results
usually take very long i think versus
investment banking where i worked for a
while where you have a deal and you know
you have an exit or an ipo it's a six
month process here in vc an exit or an
ipo it's a seven year process so it's
it's much longer paced um so the results
you actually need to be very patient uh
to get to the result um
not to like uh make mistakes along the
way and make sure you actually arrive
where you want to where you're heading
um so i think uh and then i think uh
also what inspires us a lot specifically
at flashpoint is our team i think we
were able to actually collect a
tremendous team over the last uh you
know almost nine years and i'm very
thankful for everyone who is around us
um and it's not been easy at any point
in time uh but i think uh having people
uh like that is truly inspiring because
they're supporting you they're they're
driving you they're inspiring you some
of this
within our organization we have we have
we have people who joined us like very
early and they've become our partners so
people have grown let's say from
analysts associate level to become
partners of the organization and to me
it's truly inspiring as well to see how
your own organization is building and
developing i think it's probably one of
the also most exciting things that we
are
we're doing
i love it and if you had to describe
your work or yourself in three words or
so what what three words would you
choose
yeah it's
it's not an easy one uh well maybe
yeah maybe i
uh looking through the eyes of other
people i would try to describe myself so
i think
my mom probably thinks i'm curious i'm a
curious person uh
my wife probably thinks i'm a stubborn
person
and my sons or my children they're i i i
think they think i'm a patient person
uh so that's probably how i can describe
myself i don't know
i love it alex thank you so much for
your time
i love the fact that you're doubling
down on the israeli ecosystem i'm i i
didn't realize that proptech and
construction tech are such a big part of
what's happening here it's amazing that
that out of your investment so many of
them have been in israel in the proptech
in construction tech space and i think
that one of the things that i that i
still i'm still thinking about from what
he said before about you know the red
flags and the way that you're observing
some opportunities is that it's it's not
just the team it's not just a product of
the market you have to also look at
and understand financially what's been
happening is the company setting itself
up for success in the long run
and and i think that that's obviously
something that you only really learn to
evaluate with time and with experience
yeah which i'll obviously have so alex
thank you very much for the time and
inspiration and stay safe
[Music]